[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
at 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10 our
top story far too high overall migration
jumps to 606
000 driven up by students and workers
from outside the EU
also tonight A man is arrested after his
car crashed into the downage street
Gates police say the incident is not
Terror related
the end of a three-day search in
Portugal police investigating Madeleine
McCann's disappearance say they've sent
materials for testing
energy bills to stay high even after the
price cap Falls as the chancellor says
he'd step in again to help struggling
households Plus
the Premier League managers getting the
most bang for their bucks but it's not
who you'd expect
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's coming up
in our press preview from 10 30.
thank you
[Music]
hello there good evening it is the
conservative promise made 13 years ago
to bring immigration down to the tens of
thousands today the gulf between that
pledge and reality is the biggest it's
ever been leading even the prime
minister to admit that the number of
people arriving in the UK compared to
those leaving is far too high well net
migration for last year now stands at
six hundred and six thousand inflated by
resettlement schemes for Ukraine and
Hong Kong we're on the data and the
impact on communities jobs and public
services in a moment making the front
pages too as you can see but first our
political editor Beth Rigby has more
remember this net migration needs to
come down radically from hundreds of
thousands a year to just tens of
thousands years of missed targets and
broken promises We Believe sustainable
numbers are the tens of thousands the
numbers will come down because we'll be
able to control the system
immigration there is
months to today hitting a new record
high over 600
000 net arrivals last year giving this
government a very big political problem
indeed net migration to the United
Kingdom is far too high under the
points-based system we introduced post
brexit we can control immigration we
must control immigration and we will the
right wing of the party running out of
patience the anger and frustration of my
uh constituents is being focused on
illegal migration up until now but that
anger and frustration will grow when
they consider these legal migration
figures some people in the treasury seem
to think that a good way to grow the
economy is to fill the country up with
more and more people
but this is bad for productivity and bad
for British workers who are being
undercut by mass migration from all over
the world immigration is the home
secretary's brief Under Pressure
swerving questions Home Secretary are
you failing to get immigration down are
we losing control of UK borders
labor quick to attack but refusing to
set targets of its own I would expect
net migration figures to come down for
these really unusually high levels they
are of course I think twice the level
that ministers were aiming for so that
is part of the chaos really that we've
got in the home office and this
continual and massive gap between the
rhetoric from conservative ministers and
the reality
in 2019 the conservatives promised to
cut legal migration to below quarter of
a million it's now more than double that
figure so forget the problems around
illegal Boat Crossings legal migration
is now a huge political problem for the
Prime Minister and there are no easy
solutions as Mr sunac tries to balance
the demands of the economy with voter
frustration at record high numbers for
which the conservatives think that they
could be punished at the next general
election
one man they still fear on the sidelines
hinting a comeback Parliament and the
government have ignored the will of the
people they've ignored what was said in
that brexit referendum and so now
a bigger question emerges as to how
we're going to change politics Take Back
Control stop the boats the slogans are
easy the delivery anything but and the
pressure now really on Beth Rigby Sky
News Westminster
so net migration is now three times
higher than it was before brexit with
the majority of people traveling here to
study work or for humanitarian reasons
Tom Cheshire has been taking a closer
look at the data
even if net migration wasn't quite as
high as some people predicted it is
still a big big number 606
000 a record for a calendar year leaders
of both the main political parties want
it to be smaller even if they won't say
what their preferred number is and
actually there may be some time it's
already coming down it did seem to Peak
in September and the office for National
statistics has spoken of a leveling off
it's important to note that this is a
number very much set by the government
we'll take you back some of this data
isn't directly comparable because of a
change in how it's calculated but you
get the broad Trend so at the end of
2019 over here non-eu immigration
overtakes immigration from the EU and
then it soars upwards that is the brexit
effect at this point government is
setting the terms of entry and this is
why non-eu immigrants are given visas to
the UK and it shows why that big number
is so hard to reduce because it's made
of smaller numbers here that politicians
and the public actually quite light so
in the light blue bit you've got work
visas a huge part of their growth has
been for Health and Care workers
remember those staff shortages in the
NHS well that was the attempt to plug
the gap or take study visas dark blue
again deliberate government policy to
attract bright young people from around
the world and the billions they bring in
tuition fees and there's also been a big
jump in the purple that is humanitarian
visas compared to last year people from
Ukraine from Hong Kong from Afghanistan
policies which command public support so
back to the big number because it is big
in fact it's nearly as big as adding an
entire Glasgow to the country in the
space of a year in terms of the
population it's also a useful way of
thinking about impact support the
population of Glasgow the city has nine
main hospitals 140 primary schools
around 300 000 houses now it's not a
direct comparison the immigration
population is obviously dispersed and
for schools in the NHS there's another
thing happening here in terms of
immigrants they tend to be younger than
old British people so get few your
people over 65 so less pressure over the
NHS and then you have fewer people in
terms of proportion under 15 years old
so less pressure on schools but housing
is certainly an issue the number of
households in Glasgow is around 300 000
that is coincidentally the same as the
government Target for building houses
that is a target it has never met it
doesn't look in danger of meeting so the
question around net migration is usually
whether it should be lower or perhaps
higher in the future which would
probably also be asking more questions
about how we match our infrastructure
now to the big number that is already
here
so what is the real life impact on the
education system jobs and housing our
communities correspondent Lisa Holland
traveled to Coventry to find out
the Midland City of Coventry population
almost 350
000 at the last census
but with net migration passing 600 000
it gives you a sense of just how many
people came to the country last year
towards double a reasonably sized
British City
International students account for more
than 200 000 of those arrivals this
group have come from all over the world
from Singapore to India and Morocco to
study at the University of Warwick
why did you want to come to the UK to
study are you experiencing a very very
different lifestyle you know do you
think most people who've come to study
from abroad will stay in the UK when
they finish their courses I know most
people that I know from my course in
third year finally have got their grad
job or Masters in the UK so I would say
yes most most part yeah they will stay
over a third of the University's student
population are currently from overseas
its highest ever level
but whatever the upside there are
questions which we all remember people
were asking on the lead up to brexit
which we're hearing again in Coventry
how many more houses do we have to build
how many more
are they going to be putting in the
hospitals are they going to be putting
more surgeries
so that's my main concern how we're
going to be able to cope because we're
not really coping now aren't we next we
meet Ricky who works in a warehouse to
be honest he seems despondent and
doesn't buy the government's argument
that so much migration is needed to fill
jobs I've tried to get into work in
different places and all it is now is
the agency
minimum wage I'm ready should we
concentrating on local people getting
them in training mop
so with unprecedented numbers of people
coming to the UK it's hard to square why
some companies are struggling to recruit
like this Veterinary Diagnostics firm
which has been advertising for a
pathologist for a year so is the problem
that this country is not doing enough to
grow its own Talent
possibly yes it is you know it is very
sad because there is a high need of that
and there's no incentive for people to
you know become a specialist at the
moment
the government says it's restricting the
rights of relatives to come with some
Visa holders and it remains committed to
reducing overall net migration but its
pledge to deliver control of borders
means the stakes on migration are higher
than ever these Holland Sky News
Coventry
police arrested a man in Downey street
today after his car crashed into the
main gate while the Prime Minister was
present the silver Kia crossed Whitehall
then drove directly into the barriers
officers say the incident is not Terror
related
well our correspondent Liz Bates is in
Downey Street this evening Liz
well as you can see it's all back to
normal down here the traffic is moving
through
very different just a few hours ago this
whole area was shut down there was
police tape there was dozens of offices
and there was a car wedged against the
gates of Downing Street being poured
over by the security services they were
looking for evidence to try to make
sense of what had just happened here
it's the heart of government the prime
minister's workplace and his home but
today Downing streets defenses were
tested
It All Happened without warning late in
the afternoon
this silver Kia appeared to emerge from
a car park on Whitehall near the
ministry of Defense at around 20 past
four it then crossed the road near the
cenotaph before abruptly breaking and
then driving directly into the Downing
Street Gates
quickly surrounded by police the man
inside was arrested the area shut down
suddenly behind this is this massive
crash and we're all shocked we kind of
look around we didn't know what it was
we thought it was a kind of mini
explosion when we first heard it and the
first thing I noticed is just a swarm of
police officers they were on the scene
immediately the Prime Minister had
already been removed from number 10 when
the confirmation came it wasn't being
treated as a terrorist incident but a
reminder for the police here it's high
stakes sometimes with just seconds to
respond I think the police are being
restrained they're very well trained you
would have had significant number of
firearms officers there it's one of the
most CCTV place in in the country as we
discovered with partygate and so if
there were any concerns then you'd be
having these resources moving in very
very quickly to deal with it and there
are police resources all around this
area
the quick removal of the car and
reopening of the roads would have come
as a relief to westminster's thousands
of staff and security all too familiar
with being a Target
the famous street was once unguarded but
in 1989 under threat from the IRA Gates
were erected this didn't stop though an
IRA attack on the then prime minister
John Major and his cabinet just two
years later can you get your people away
from these windows when three mortar
shells launched into the Estate One
exploding in the garden luckily no
serious damage was done
today with those involved unscathed and
local police dealing with the aftermath
attention now turns to the man who drove
the car what was he doing and why and
for those inside the building a reminder
that even those in power can be
vulnerable
yes we understand that it wasn't just
the Prime Minister that was here today
it was the chancellor as well Rishi
sunak left quite quickly we don't know
understandably whether he's returned
tonight I think worth noting as well
there's been a lot of praise for the
police today people here saying not only
did they contain this incident but they
dealt with it very calmly and that's of
course in the end meant that everybody
involved left unscathed including that
driver he put himself of course in a lot
of danger as well as other people today
and he'll be praying he'll be facing uh
questions I think tonight from police as
to what exactly happened
Liz thank you
a three-day search for clues about
Madeleine McCann's disappearance ended
in Portugal today with unspecified
samples being sent for testing but the
German prosecutor on the case has played
down hopes of a breakthrough journalists
were allowed onto the site after
restrictions were lifted our Europe
correspondent Siobhan Robbins was among
them
this is what it looks like behind the
Cordon of the latest search for
Madeleine McCann for three days police
have been scouring this land on the edge
of a reservoir 30 miles from where she
went missing
a favorite haunt of the prime suspect in
her disappearance signs of police
activity are all around
here the trees which they cut down to
get access to areas of Interest land
cleared as they tried to find Clues
well you can see here some of the holes
that appear to have been dug as part of
this search potentially taking away soil
for example
and Portuguese police have said evidence
has been removed from the scene for
further testing
German prosecutors suspect known sex
offender Christian B was involved in
Madeleine's disappearance he denies it
the toddler was staying here in the
resort of prai deluge when she went
missing in 2007.
the church in the town prays for her
every Sunday Pat and Sheila had been
visiting the area for decades we were
here when it actually happened
very sad the whole thing and we talked
about it this time
it's for them if they found something it
would be closure I think that's the best
thing and that's the only way I would
look at it
the first search for Madeleine McCann in
Portugal for almost a decade is over
the machines used to clear the land have
moved out any evidence collected will
now be tested in Germany as they try to
solve the mystery of what happened to
this little girl
Siobhan Robbins Sky News in Portugal
they are the hospitals literally falling
apart and threatened with closure
because of safety issues caused by
deteriorating concrete today the health
secretary pledged 320 billion pounds to
help rebuild seven sites across the
country as our health correspondent
Ashish Joshi reports
so this is one of our operating theaters
that's currently under repair NHS
leaders are used to working under
pressure but here at Friendly Park
Hospital time is running out we've been
working at this since last October
almost two-thirds of the roof here is
made of concrete that is breaking down
it's known as rack and it's falling
apart
this was identified a number of years
ago and we've had an extensive
surveillance and safety program in place
that's enabled us to identify any issues
or risks before they happen and as you
can see take remedial action and
reinforcement where they're needed but
importantly that isn't a long-term
solution the Queen Elizabeth's Hospital
in King's Lynn is facing the same
challenge in all seven hospitals have
until 2030 to fix their buildings or
face being closed down
now they're all being included in the
government's new hospitals program
today's announcement confirms over 20
billion pounds of investment for the NHS
estate it confirms that all seven Iraq
hospitals which NHS leaders have called
on the government to provide prioritize
will be prioritized but relief for some
means delays for others eight large
schemes at hospitals like Preston Royal
Berkshire and St Mary's in London will
now be delayed until after 2030. leaking
sewage rat infestations collapsing roofs
we are in this mess because of
conservative neglect and mismanagement
they literally didn't fix the roof while
the Sun was shining and now patient
safety is at risk
in addition to the new hospitals program
the government has also announced plans
to give patients more control over where
they receive their health care including
private options
the Prime Minister has promised to bring
down the seven million strong elective
waiting list
GPS welcome the principle of Greater
choice but say that it could present
more work without addressing the issue
what we're not doing is we're not
increasing capacity we do have a set
number of appointments available and we
have a set number of patients and
unfortunately the rate of patients
increasing population growth versus
their appointments are available
clinical staff is not matching
new hospitals more choice for patients
both welcome but reliant on a Workforce
plan that is yet to be published Josh is
Sky News at frimley Park Hospital
Ashish there on plans or government
plans for 20 billion pounds of spending
now energy bills will remain high this
summer despite a big drop in the maximum
amount that suppliers can charge the
regulator off germ is lowering the
energy price cap from 3280 pounds per
year to 2074 pounds in England Wales and
Scotland from July but as our business
correspondent Paul Kelso explains
households aren't expected to be much
better off off gem sets the upper limit
for the price of units of gas and
electricity and then expresses those as
an annual figure the typical cost for an
average household family of four and
this is what that number has looked like
over time we go back to 2018 19 and 20
around a thousand pounds when it got to
1200 pounds after covert we thought that
was expensive but look after the
invasion of Ukraine by Russia in April
2022 up to 2000 and then more than 4 000
pounds by this winter falling back today
the cap that's been set from July 2074
pounds that's an effective saving for
households of around 500 pounds because
for the most of the period prices were
really high the government was
underwriting those costs with the energy
price guarantee here at two and a half
thousand pounds we paid the dark blue
area consumers paid that this bit the
extra that was the real cost of
electricity paid for by the treasury
that bill has already run to tens of
billions of pounds Little Wonder then
that Jeremy Hunt is pleased that prices
are finally falling like where there are
acute pressures that people face
unexpectedly we want to do everything we
can to help families I don't want to
predict today what might happen to
Energy prices at the moment we're not
expecting to see those kinds of
increases but of course we don't know
that and all I can say is that I think
I've demonstrated in the Autumn
statement and the spring budget where I
extended the energy price guarantee for
another three months funded in part by a
windfall tax on the oil companies that
we are willing to do what it takes
the chancellor then says he's ready to
act if necessary but the forecast
suggests he won't have to at these
prices so what happens next we've got
the cap set now for July 2074 pounds the
forecast say in October that will still
be just under 2 000 pounds maybe a
little bit above come January so that's
some price stability because wholesale
gas prices are pretty stable that might
mean we see some competition back in the
market we might be able to shop around
for fixed price deals to lock these in
but that's still double the long-term
average the cost of living squeeze is
going to go on even though prices are
coming down
three people have been arrested after a
demonstration by just stop oil
protesters at the Chelsea flower show
Humanity
is failing
video footage showed three people
throwing orange powder over one of the
exhibits it wasn't long before a woman
nearby picked up a hose pipe and sprayed
the protesters with water
good morning chair good morning members
good morning head of Scotland's peace
Force has admitted is institutionally
racist sexist misogynistic and
discriminatory so in Livingston who is
retiring in August made the damning
assessment office force in a meeting of
the Scottish police Authority but
insisted it was not an indictment of
individual officers police Scotland is
institutionally racist and
discriminatory
publicly acknowledging these
institutional issues exist in our
organization is essential to our
absolutely our absolute commitment to
championing equality and becoming an
anti-racist service
the leader of a far-right group in the
U.S has been sentenced to 18 years in
prison for his role in the U.S capital
riots Stuart Rhodes the founder of The
Oath Keepers stayed outside the capital
on the 6th of January 2021 but
coordinated with other members of his
group who stormed the building the
sentence is the longest given to a
capital writer
hundreds of people gather today for the
funeral of one of the last black RAF
Pilots to have fought in the second
world war flight Sergeant Peter Brown
died alone last year aged 96 and an
appeal to Tracy's relatives was picked
up by Community associations and the
media which contributed to today's big
send-off
now to a technological breakthrough
which it's hoped will give British
forces an advantage during war it's
called a Quantum compass and works in
situations when GPS can't be used or has
been intentionally blocked it's
currently being trialled on a royal Navy
research ship our Science and Technology
editor Tom Clarke went on board
a Sleek new Navy ship few of us knew
existed is in London after Sea Trials of
a Quantum navigation system designed to
give our armed forces the edge
we do have GPS but as has been
publicized recently sometimes that can
be interfered with or sometimes it
doesn't work so the ability to have a
new and novel way of accurately very
accurately plotting your position is
fundamental to the way the Royal Navy
and the military does business it's all
very James Bond
until you get to the technology itself
inside a shipping container surrounded
by scientists from Imperial College
we can't see inside the white box
containing the machine many of its
components are secret but a few miles
away in the labs where they developed it
is a prototype so this is a cold atom
interferometer at heart so we start by
cooling clouds of viridium 87 atoms down
to very very low temperatures so a few
micro Kelvin it's a few millionths of a
degree above absolute zero you can see
those rubidium atoms glowing red in
these pictures in this Quantum State the
particles also behave as waves allowing
the researchers to measure acceleration
and Pitch with Incredible precision
but real waves not Quantum ones are the
issue for practical navigation
controlling and measuring the subatomic
properties of matter is hard enough to
do in a laboratory setting so what this
trial is really about is seeing whether
a Quantum technology can even work out
at Sea and that's where the Navy's new
research ship comes in
so this is our first opportunity to take
our Quantum sensors out of the
laboratory clunky nylon straps hold a
precious cargo floating Quantum Mata
onto the deck this is a very exotic
environment for one of these kind of
sensors so one of the big challenges is
making it work in the real world where
things are moving magnetic fields are
changing there are lots of vibrations
that we need to manage to keep this
thing stable enough to be able to
operate it as it needs to work the trial
has shown promising results the team
hopes it will point the way to a new era
in navigation Tom Clark Sky News
now he's raised the Premier League
trophy five times a constant presence in
the Dugout for Manchester City but Sky's
analysis of 30 years of football
finances has found that despite his
success Pep Guardiola was not the
manager who got the best value for money
out of his Squad our Sports
correspondent Rob Harris can tell us who
did
he's won more than any manager now in
the Premier League and he spent the most
but how successful is Pep Guardiola
Malden arsene Wenger with the longest
unbeaten run
also Alex Ferguson with his record 13
lead titles we've been through three
decades of Premier League finances to
discover which manager gets the best
value for money out of their squads it's
not pet Guardiola winner of five Premier
League titles here at Manchester City
it's the less glamorous Sean dice
considered the most effective manager in
premier league history he's achieved the
most with the least
we found that dice while at Burnley
gained the most premier league places
compared to the wage Bill ranking he's
an over performer who Everton turned to
in January for a relegation struggle
that will only be settled on Sunday
leads are in the same fight and this is
why they parachuted some other dice in
three weeks ago he makes our top five
with Maurizio pochettino Tony pulis and
Gordon Strachan are statistically the
most successful managers
on the other end of the scale though the
special one turns out not so special
despite three League titles at Chelsea
Jose Mourinho significantly
underachieved based on his resources
Financial strength Club good players and
many many reasons another stupid to
realize without this incredible clubs
I've been I could not achieve what we
achieve he's been at City Seven Seasons
rare longevity in The Dugout especially
in this season with a record 14 managers
being sacked
clubs hope new bosses produce immediate
wins a bounce initially achieved when
dice replaced Frank Lampard at Everton
but the form dropped
Nathan Jones couldn't reverse fortunes
to keep Southampton up allodice can
still at Leeds
Thomas Frank has shown how to exceed
expectations at Brentford so what are
the secrets of success in The Dugout
Clear Vision
consistent in messages
consistent Behavior
every single day
um I think that's key a key we found to
judgey managerial success isn't always
the Trope is one
but how they make the most out of the
cash they have to spend
Rob Harris Sky News
[Applause]
well that was Sky News at 10 coming up
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
newspapers in the Press preview
including this on the front of the Metro
their headline units are told get out of
the migration business tonight we're
joined by the editor of The Courier
David Clegg and the Daily Express
columnist and broadcaster Carol Merlin
[Music]
thank you